six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's check
out the oh I don't know where do we want
to go next maybe the seven three two
area card it's been a while since we
went to seven three two and seven three
two can bring really good things or it
can sometimes grind the show to a halt
so we'll see what seven three two does
for us today go ahead seven three two
hey how's it going David good yeah I
wish I could say the same but you know
this Supreme Court
you know Justice Kennedy stepping down
and the possibility of another you know
super conservative Neil Gorsuch type is
really stressing me out and I've been
pretty upset with Barack Obama of all
people about it because I feel like he
did not see any of this coming and he
didn't try to set his legacy in place
where it'll be beneficial to his actual
constituents and he didn't take Trump
seriously or take the conservative
seriously at all and I don't know who
you placed the plan do you place the
blame with Obama I mean obviously the
conservative the Mitch McConnell did all
this but I feel like the Democratic
Party never took seriously just how
ghoulish the Republicans can be so let
me see I want to make sure I know what
your argument is you're saying that
President Obama President Obama for not
having taken Trump seriously enough
which led to his election and
subsequently him getting to choose a
replacement for Anthony Kennedy is that
is that what you're saying I think yeah
I would say it's Obama's fault for not
you know making it so precarious that
the only liberal justices left are in
their late 70s and mid eighties because
unfortunately they can also step down
and we could have up to a 72
conservative liberal court and I just
don't think that there was the foresight
to say hey maybe maybe Ruth Bader bins
uh sorry uh Ginsburg should step down
during you know 2011 we got a younger
liberal justice and it just seems that
there wasn't that kind of planning for
an event like what happened
I don't know I mean you you can what
you're talking about is Obama going to
Ruth Bader Ginsburg in 2011 and saying
that we might lose seats if the next
person is a Republican so I want you to
step down now so I can put in someone
younger that's not anywhere near the top
of the list of who deserves the blame
the blame mostly goes to people who
voted for Trump then it goes to people
who didn't vote who would have voted for
someone else but they didn't find it
apparently important enough to vote then
it goes to Republicans who successfully
obstructed Merrick garland when it was
the end of President Obama's
administration so there's tons of blame
to go around and Obama's he's on the
list but he's not high on the list the
way you're suggesting I guess
all right we're losing you it seems like
your connections imploding I understand
and appreciate the question and and
hopefully I was able to give you at
least somewhat somewhat of an answer
there